el expresidente argentino mauricio macri
finalmente se presentó ante el tribunal
más que compareció en el juzgado de
dolores provincia de buenos aires para
responder sobre el presunto espionaje a
los familiares de los 44 tripulantes del
submarino militar desaparecido el 15 de
noviembre de 2017 el ex presidente y su
defensa argumentan que la acusación
tiene motivaciones políticas debido a
las elecciones legislativas en argentina
el próximo 14 de noviembre y que estamos
en presencia de un juez manifiestamente
incompetente en todo sentido un juez que
no tiene imparcialidad y un juez que
días pasados demostró y desnudo su
dependencia del poder ejecutivo y los
intereses políticos apuros que hay
detrás de esta causa la investigación a
cargo del juez se remonta a septiembre
de 2020 cuando la agencia federal
denunció que el anterior gobierno espía
a los familiares de los tripulantes
fallecidos ellos alegan que han sido
intimidados para disuadirlos de
presentar una demanda cuando fue
encontrada a 900 metros de profundidad
la nave lara sanjuán un año después de
su desaparición ya nos han seguido nos
han intervenido
perfilado durante por lo menos un año de
manera sistemática y organizada esta es
la cuarta situación emitida por el juez
federal martín bava al ex presidente
quien faltó a dos citaciones judiciales
previas la primera por encontrarse en el
extranjero y la segunda por no tener
autorización del actual gobierno para
contestar a las preguntas sobre el
servicio de inteligencia lo cual fue
revertido por el actual presidente
alberto fernández a través de un decreto
sin embargo en aquella ocasión macri
únicamente entregó una declaración
escrita
aunque la investigación por el
hundimiento concluyó que se trató de un
accidente las investigaciones por las
escuchas ilegales apenas comienzan